Today's case,
like Michael V.
Price deals with what's called a requirement's contract.
Hanley t price sold sand through his business,
the sooner sand company he and Mcmichael entered into a contract in which
mcmichael agreed to supply price with all the sand that price could resell for
the next 10 years at a price of 60% of the market price at the sands
destination.
So Price,
Aka sooner sand is the plaintiff and the purchaser from Mcmichael.
It's a little bit confusing because it seems that price,
uh,
speaks,
the cons contract speaks as price as being the seller,
but he's actually a reseller of sand that he buys from Mcmichael.
So after some time,
uh,
under this contract,
Ma Mcmichael refuse to continue supplying price with sand.
And so price sued to enforce the contract.
At the trial,
the jury awarded price $7,500.
Though the judge reduced that to $5,000 through remittitur order.
Mcmichael argued in this case that is contract with price was invalid because
the contract was not mutual.
If price decided to go out of business,
he would no longer be obligated to purchase any sand for Mcmichael.
In particular,
Mcmichael pointed out that price had quote no established business and was not
bound to sell any sand whatsoever unquote.
We are reading the decision from the Oklahoma Supreme Court.
That's one reasons it's called sooner sand because it's as sooner state.
The court must decide whether requirement contracts are void for lack of
mutuality because the purchaser can avoid his obligation by going out of
business.
The court finds that this is not the case.
Each of the parties does have an obligation under the contract price.
The purchaser reseller must not buy sand from anyone else.
If price does mcmichael could sue him for breach of contract,
you should see that this promise not to buy from anyone else is illegal
detriment.
That helps satisfy the consideration requirement.
Mcmichael the seller must sell price for its side of the contract for its
promise.
All the sand that price needs.
This form of contract is called a requirements contract and it's one where a
seller agrees to supply all of a purchaser's requirements in exchange for a
promise that the purchaser will buy exclusively from that seller and output
contract is in a sense the reverse.
A buyer agrees to purchase all of the supplier's product in exchange for the uh,
suppliers promise not to sell to anyone else in order for requirements and
output contracts and indeed for other contracts to be valid,
the contracts must be mutual.
That is they must bind both parties.
Neither party can have a freeway out of the contract.
Both must be making actual commitments that might be breached.
This is the consideration for each other's promise.
Must be something that if it's not given,
would give rise to a breach of contract action.
Courts generally haven't considered the exact level of commitment to be
important.
That is,
it's up to the parties themselves to negotiate just what they are bound to or
not bound to under the uniform commercial code,
the purchaser and a requirements contract like the one in Mcmichael v price has
the duty to also make reasonable efforts to generate sales.
Section two three Oh six subparagraph one provides that a term which measures
the quantity by the output of the seller or the requirements.
The buyer means such actual output or requirements as may occur in good faith,
except that no quantity unreasonably disproportionate to any stated estimate may
be tendered or demanded under the UCC.
Then Mcmichael would have a legal claim against price if he decided to stop
selling sand entirely.
Uh,
for no good reason.
Parties have a responsibility to stick relatively close to any estimates they
gave when negotiating the contract for our requirements are an output agreement.
Though they are allowed to fluctuate somewhat based on their actual business
needs.
So under the UCC,
which of the following would violate price and Mick Michael's contract a price
makes no effort to resell and never order sand from Mcmichael be mcmichael
refuses to sell price more than half the amount of sand price at estimated.
He would need see price orders from Mcmichael 20 times more sand than he
suggested he would need or d,
all of the above.
Okay,
well all of these accidents here would violate either the terms of the contract
or section two,
three Oh six of the UCC.
The estimated amount of sand is presumptively reasonable.
And so mcmichael his refusal to sell price more than half the estimated amount
violates his promise.
If price requests,
uh,
no sand or 20 times as much sand as he said he would need,
a court would likely find that the amount required were unreasonably
disproportionate to the,
uh,
earlier estimates.
If price made reasonable efforts and could not sell any sand,
that might not be a breach,
but important questions arise as to how much effort and whether the resale must
be profitable
in mcmichael versus price.
We have seen that the requirement of mutuality simply means that both parties
must have obligations under a contract in order for that contract to be valid.
A good test for whether parties have ob a mutual obligations is what is judged,
uh,
is whether judged at the moment of contracting,
there is some course of action they could take for which the other party could
sue them for breach of contract.
In particular,
requirement contracts and output contracts are enforceable because of the
exclusivity and reasonable efforts promises these can be violated if you buy or
sell a from the wrong person.
We have also seen that the uniform commercial code requires purchasers and
requirement contracts and suppliers and output contracts to make good firth good
faith efforts to stick to any estimates they gave when they were negotiating
their contracts.